[Music]
10 minute game we're 1673 thank you
svarag 42
and 15 16 25 so we
definitely climbing up okay d6 so that's
either a perk or a philidor this could
mean a lot of different moves
we play d4
okay d6 and c6
so this is
this system exists
um and again it's quite a flexible
system black generally follows up with
knight f6 and then we transpose into
some sort of
uh some sort of a perk
variation so white strategy here is no
different than how we usually play we
don't need to overthink it we just
develop
and depending on how black plays okay g6
so there we go now we have a perk
um with with an early c6 which is a
viable continuation and how we want to
play with white depends on
how ambitious we want to get the most
ambitious system is to play f4
and and play the austrian attack setup
there literally are a million ways we
can position our pieces with white
and there is no correct answer here
there's bishop b3
there's bishop c4 like we can really do
whatever we want
but let's let's play ambitiously in this
game let's play f4 i feel like
f4 knight f3 especially against this
early c6 is a pretty good is a pretty
good set up bishop g4
okay so double
bishop development the point of bishop
g4 is to potentially take on f3
and distract our queen so that d4 is
weak
so we want to develop with an eye toward
defending
this either this pawn or protecting this
knight so either bishop b2
or i like bishop e3 even more because it
takes the sting out of bishop takes f3
and we might not even need bishop e2
queen b6 yeah this is theory
and now um
the theoretical move as far as i
remember is queen up to d2
i think this is the move and the point
is queen takes b2 can now be met with
rook b1 and bishop takes f3 we're not
afraid of okay
big deal you know we have a double pawn
here
this is really not a big deal we still
have a monster center and remember that
in such lines we can castle queenside so
this could actually benefit us the fact
that we have these doubled pawns because
it kind of opens up the g file and you
can imagine a scenario where black
castles king side and we can use these
pawns as kind of battering rams we can
go f4 f5 and try to shatter black's king
position
so how should we proceed here
knight f6
how should we proceed in this position
well not h4 yet i think it's a little
bit too early to play h4
because we don't even know where black
is gonna castle i think we need to start
by castling and completing our
development and if black castles okay
which he just did
now we can start thinking about
attacking the king side but remember
from an earlier conversation that
when i say attack the king's side you
guys automatically start thinking h4h5
and h4 is a great move here but it's not
the only way to shatter black's king
position and we could also use our f
pawns and go f5 first
in order to soften up the king position
and then later when we play h4 it's
going to be even stronger we also can
play bishop h6 at some point all of
these moves are possible
now we can play f takes g6 here
obviously but we don't have to rush with
that because black is not exactly going
to i mean obviously black's not going to
take on f5 and open up the g file we
would love for that to happen so now i
think we should go h4 and push the pawn
all the way up to h5 and create maximal
pressure on the g6 pawn he just allows
us to go h5 notice that i'm completely
ignoring what black is doing on the
queen side why why am i so sure that
black's queen side attack is actually
not strong well it has to do with the
fact that black has no pieces there
there are no pieces on the queen on the
queen side and if we put our king on b1
when you've got all of these pieces
clustered together if necessary they can
come back and
and lend a hand so this is already very
very precarious for black where should
the knight go well the knight doesn't
have too many possibilities we can go
knight a4 and use the knight as a as a
door stopper
we can also but the maneuver that i
really like is 92
getting the knight to f4 in order to
intensify the pressure on g6 even
further now you might look at this and
say well wait a minute this blocks the
bishop i kind of wanted my bishop on c4
yeah but that's temporary this is
completely temporary knight is going to
move
okay so we're already completely winning
and before playing knight f4 i think the
time has come for us to capture on g6
twice
so that black gets an isolated g6 pawn
so that when we play knight f4
we not only attack the g6 bomb but we
also aim for the e6 square
which is going to be weakened by the
fact that the f7 pawn is no longer going
to be there that f7 pawn is going to be
on g6 watch so hg6 we're decimating the
king
position now we take again
and
we can also go bishop h3 bishop e6
that's another great maneuver but let's
complete what we started with knight f4
does that make sense the 92
is a frankfurt airport move our knight
had no plans to remain on e2
now we're threatening a
load of different possibilities first of
all there's knight takes g6 there's
knight e6 there's bishop c4 check which
is totally devastating the king
literally has no squares
and of course you also probably can
notice that
our queen can get into the action with
queen g2 if necessary king f7 that's a
good defensive move but it's not going
to help so
in such positions it's important not to
get overwhelmed by the abundance of
possibilities generally what you're
going to find is that there are multiple
ways to continue the attack don't
necessarily try to look for okay i have
to find the one move right there's
probably going to be two or three good
moves and my first inclination
is to
as i
as we've talked about increase the
pressure on g6 right if we can take the
pawn on g6
blacks black is going to be crushed
i'll explain after the game why i'm not
as convinced of bishop c4 although
bishop c4 is completely winning bishop
c4 check
d5 e takes d5 and then we're threatening
d6 with a discovery but we have a very
elegant move here that wins the g6 pawn
with totally decisive effect what should
we attack g6 with well what piece do you
want on g6 think about it what's the
optimal piece
that if it appears on g6 leads to
essentially instant checkmate
well think about it obviously the queen
well can we get the queen there we guess
we can we can play queen g2 this is not
the easiest move to see actually it's
kind of a little bit hidden but it's
crushing on the spot because this pawn
simply cannot be defended and once we
capture it black's hole position
collapses queen g2 is the game-winning
move and i think it's probably the most
accurate too according to the engine but
we'll check that's absolutely not true
that only grandmasters see this move
it's quite a straightforward move if you
think about it
and i i hope i walked you through the
logic um
of finding it right and
it's not like only i see that this pawn
is weak we all see that the g6 pawn is
weak
you all want to attack it it's pretty
straightforward
it's a little bit hard to see but
the logic behind it is very
straightforward okay now let's put the
finishing touches on the attack and once
again there are many many ways
that we can do this um probably the
nicest maneuver that that i notice here
is bishop h3 and bishop e6 i mentioned
it earlier if we can get a bishop to e6
it's checkmate on the spot
now we might say well why not bishop c4
check well bishop c4 check runs into d5
which incidentally is also completely
winning for white oh and in that
position no no no let's go bishop c4
check because what i just noticed
is that after d5 our rook from d1 can
swing over to g1 threatening checkmate
on g7 now it's all hands on deck
and after rook f7 which is forced we
have a very elegant mating idea
who can find
a an a simple but elegant mating idea
this is a move which sets up a
quote-unquote sacrifice it's really not
such a big deal
it's just
mate
so rookie chad is winning rookie chad is
totally winning king takes h8 and then
queen takes f7 but perhaps even nicer
is the move knight e6 threatening queen
takes g7 check
and then rook takes g7 checkmates there
are literally
30 different ways that we could com that
we could uh convert this attack into the
full point again
don't you know if you're asking a
question along the lines of why not this
or why not that the answer is probably
that you we could have done that also
okay and now we have checkmate in one
move queen h7 noticing that
98 what square does it relinquish when
you're attacking you have to pay very
careful attention to all of the squares
at your disposal because
it's easy to miss a checkmate if you're
not fully attentive to
okay all of the squares you have access
to
and a simple simple enough attack
and that's why i don't really recommend
the perk at this level
because this is often what happens
okay so
g6 f4 bishop g7 so this is a legitimate
line that he played
but it's not a very good line it's a
legitimate line it's it's been played
before but it's not a very good line
and according to the opening explorer in
this position knight f6 is already
inaccurate
most people play knight d7
and after queenside castles
91 games continued queen a5
with a quick b5 before black has to get
things going on the queen side because
if he procrastinates
then well you saw what happens to black
and this whole line is very very dubious
the center is monstrous
and white can just go king b1 here b5 b4
is really not the end of the world we
can just start on our attack with h4
why is queen takes me too bad for him
it's
it's not losing but it's it's it's very
dubious we just go rook b1 and rook
takes p7
and we have a monster rook on the
seventh rank whereas the queen
isn't a very effective attacker in and
of itself
um so so queen b2 is never and even
sometimes you sacrifice this one in some
cases you want to sacrifice b2
and i had a very nice game like that
against alexander lenderman
many years ago
i had a game in a very similar line
where lenderman i sacked a pawn like
that on b2 and he took it and
you know i got a crushing attack really
really quickly
the queen is a supporting actress that's
right i can show you that game if you
guys want
this is from 2011 he was already a gm i
was an im
so basically it was a slightly different
opening
it was e4
g6
d4 bishop g7 knight c3
c6 bishop e3 and queen b6 and here i
decided to sacrifice the b2 pawn with
queen d2
which lenderman took
and basically it's not like white has
any
insane idea it's just that i thought i
have a very big lead in development and
the queen on a3 is misplaced and here
lendy
he he played a very bad move b5 which is
a blunder
um it's a pretty high level blunder it's
not like this blunders the queen in one
move or something
does anybody see
why this is a big mistake
no i open the game i'm not going for
memory
bishop takes b5 is right
and after cb knight b5 queen a2
so i found a way to win but i didn't
find the best way to win the move that
won on the spot here there's a brilliant
move
that wins on the spot
i'll give you guys a chance to find it
it's not knight c7 check
i know most of you are probably thinking
that knight c7 check this is what i
played
and after king d8
um i i castled basically sacrificing two
pieces but winning the queen because my
queen's coming into a5 so black is
forced to give up his queen but black
gets a lot of stuff for the queen
the move is is queen c3
very quiet but totally deadly
you might look at this and say well i
don't understand why is this such an
amazing whipple because first of all
with threatening checkmate
so queen takes b1 king d2 is game over
because we're going to win the queen
obviously this is the
the cool line
but
the secondary problem for black is that
if black plays a move like knight c6 we
go rook a1
and the queen is trapped because queen
e6 runs into a fork so that's it here
black only gets a rook and a piece for
the queen and a bunch of pawns and the
attack is totally crushing
so this literally could have been like
an eleven move game but it just shows
you that you know these pawns on b2
often are
you know you can sacrifice them without
really a second thought
okay back to our game
once our opponent castled i already
think this position is horrible
i just don't black's attack is so slow
here and we're already like crashing
through basically
yeah maybe i mean the problem is if
black goes h5 there was a question
before the problem is that this softens
the g6 pawn
and effectively it has the same effect
of us playing h5 like it's the same
exact concept here
yeah i don't recommend the perk to
almost anybody it's just incredibly high
maintenance you got in all this theory
and then you make one mistake and you
get destroyed like this
knight takes h5 what would we do
i mean
here
we could consider sacking on h5 but
that's probably unnecessary you know
what i would probably do here
i would stack my queen on h2
you might look at this and say well i
don't understand
what are we doing well we're going to
get rid of the knight obviously
right you're just preemptively stacking
the queen in the rook how are we going
to get rid of the knight we're going to
use one of our minor pieces we're either
going to go
bishop h3 bishop g4
or we're going to go with the maneuver
we had in the game knight e2 knight f4
knight 92 knight g3
and uh i i just don't see in the long
run how black is going to survive here
so my mic is acting up no i think i
think it's fine
no and after b492 it's the same concept
if knight takes h5 we can go knight f4
trade the knight and then get our queen
to h2
attacking in these kinds of positions is
quite straightforward and once we get
the knight to f4 there are too many weak
squares too many weak pawns
and the win is very straightforward here
so
there were a couple of things in the
opening i could talk about so for
example
okay f4 i think i explained clearly do
you ever go f4 e5 yeah you go e5 in
these positions i mean normally you wait
for black to go knight f6 yeah e5 is
even a move here
e5 is even a movie although it's a
little bit premature generally you
develop your miners first before going
e5 could you give more insight on
finding the queen move so i assume you
mean quincy too
okay so
first of all when you're attacking you
have to have a bird's-eye view of what
are the the i i call this thinking in
terms of squares what are the weakest
squares what are the infiltration points
that you ideally want to use to
infiltrate right that's not a
crazy concept well when i look at this
position i see two such squares i see e6
and g6 just because
it you don't you know need any skill to
see that you just sort of just see it
um now in order to get to e6 we can go
bishop c4 check and so that's why i said
this is also winning bishop c4 check is
a legitimate move
but the second pawn is g6 and then
i think what you know when you guys hear
that
you might think of rook g1 but the extra
step that i take is i say well what
piece ideally do i want on g6 right not
just like randomly attacking that pawn
but rather saying
okay i want a queen on g6 because the
queen on g6 would be mating
that's it then you find queen she too
i mean that's that's as detailed as i
can go i mean
you know once you understand the logic
of this move you shouldn't understand
why it's why it's so strong
[Music]
you